اعلن القضاء الايراني اعدام علي رضا اكبر
مساعد وزير الدفاع السابق بتهمه التجسس
لصالح الاستخبارات البريطانيه والعمل ضد
امن الدوله في الداخل وخارج البلاد وفق
تعبيره وكان علي رضا اكبر مساعدا لوزير
الدفاع علي شمخاني خلال فتره الرئيس
السابق محمد خاتمي وكانت الاستخبارات
الايرانيه اعلنت في وقت سابق ان علي رضا
اكبر كان يتجسس على مراكز الحساسه
والاستراتيجيه لايران واعتقل قبل ثلاث
سنوات بعد عمليه طويله ومعقده واشارت الى
ان اكبر كان يجمع المعلومات ويوصلها الى
من وصفتهم باستخبارات الاعداء قالت لنا
الاستخبارات البريطانيه
سقطبته اثناء سفره الى اوروبا وحصل على
الجنسيه البريطانيه بعد ذلك
اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفر
لي فرض عقوبات على النائب العامه الايراني
للتعبير عما وصفه بشمئزازي بريطانيا من
اعدام المواطن البريطانيه الايرانيه علي
رضا اكبر
بدوره عبر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك عن صدمته لاعدام علي رضا اكبر ووصف
في تغريده الاعدام بانه عمل قاسم وجبان
نفذه نظام همجي لا يحترم حقوق الانسان
لشعبه
لقد استدعت الخارجيه الايرانيه السفيره
لبريطانيه في طهران احتجاجا على ما وصفتها
بافعال مخربه ومهدده للامن القومي
الايرانيه وقدت الخارجيه الايرانيه انها
طلبت من السفير البريطاني تقديمات توضيحات
بشان استقطاب بريطانيا علي رضا اكبر مساعد
وزير الدفاع الايراني الاسبق واجراء
اتصالات الغير قانونيه معه تناسب الامن
القومي الايراني واكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه
لن تقبل استمرار هذه الاجراءات غير
القانونيه وان على بريطانيا تحمل مسؤوليه
تدخلها في شؤون ايران الداخلي
تبع التطورات مع مراسيلنا من طهران نور
الدين غير مع مراسينا من لندن اسد الله
صافي اهلا بكم نور الدين والموقع في سهران
بعد استدعاء السفير البريطاني ما الذي جرى
[موسيقى]
نعم مريم
في ما يخص عمليه اعدام علي رضا اكبر يهون
في الرساله
[موسيقى]
بقضيه مزدوج الجنسيه
الجنسيه غير مطروح لدى الايرانيين وانما
يتم التعامل مع الجنسيه الاصليه الطرف
المعني وهنا الحديث على ان علي رضا اكبر
لكن لانه خرق القوانين والاعراف الامنيه
وهنا في طهران فبالتالي كان لابد من اصدار
هذا الحكم هكذا يتحدث
عن وزاره الاستخبارات او وزاره
همم العدل اهو او اداره القضاء هنا في
طهران لكن بكل تاكيد هنا الحديث الايراني
على ان من يجب ان يتحمل المسؤوليه من هو
في موضع التساؤل هي الحكومه البريطانيه هي
اجت استخبارات البريطانيه لانه كما يقول
الايرانيون هنا هي من عملت على جذب
واستقطاب شخصيه ليست بالمهمه وليست في
الهينه مهمه من درجه علي رضا اكبر الرجل
اذا ما تم عنا في تاريخ السياسي وتاريخه
الامني ليس بالشخصيه البسيطه بكلام هو
الرجل المشرف على تنفير اتفاق اطلاق النار
ما بين ايران والعراق وبالتالي هو حاضر
بشكل كبير في الاجهزه العسكريه هنا في
ايران كان نائبا لوزير الدفاع في عهد
حكومه الرئيس محمد خاتم وبالتالي هذا
المنصب ليس بالمنصب العين الكثير من
المعلومات التي ترتبط بالجانب العسكري
بجانب الصواريخ
كذلك كان حاضرا ضمن الفريق الايراني
الذي استمر ما بين عام 2006 وعام 2007
حينما كان عالرجاني امنا لمجلس الامن
القومي الايراني وبالتالي هذا الاحتجاج
الان الايراني باستدعاء الصفير البريطاني
هنا في طهران كان مرضه هو استقطاب
واستقدام شخصيه رسميه هنا في طهران من اجل
ما تسميه طهران باستهداف الامن القومي
وبالتالي هنا تنظر طهران على ان اللون
يعود بالدرجه الاولى الى الحكومه
البريطانيه وليس للجانب الايراني باعتبار
كما يقول القضاء هنا باعتبار ان العنوان
العرض الذي يتمثل في استهداف في الامن
القومي الايراني في التجسس لصالح اجهزه
اجنبيه ودول اجنبيه وهنا يتحدث الايرانيون
على ان القانون هنا ايران قانون واضح
والحكم بالاعدام لكن مريم الاهم من ذلك
ومن هذا السيجاره القائم ما بين لندن وما
بين طهران في مساله اعدام علي رضا اكبر
ربما قد تكون الرساله الايرانيه ابعد مندل
كتابه توقفنا على عند سلسله الاعدامات
التي نفذت هنا في طهران خلال هذا الشهر
علي رضا اكبر قد يكون الرجل الخامس الذي
تسمى اعدامه هنا في طهران تم اعدام اربعه
اشخاص وذلك بتهمه استهداف الامن القومي
بعد الاحتجاجات التي وصلت اليها طراب
وبالتالي هي رساله داخليه للداخل الايراني
ان اطار الامن القومي واستهداف الامن
القومي قد تقول طهران قد يكون القضاء
الايراني انه لن تتهاون فيه ولن تتسهل مع
اي طرف يمكن ان يكون جزء من هذه المعادله
التي تستهدف الامن القومي لكن الرساله
الاهم كذلك بالنسبه الايرانيين في هذه
الظروف هي رساله للخارج اذا ما وقفنا عند
مجموعه من العقوبات التي فرضت على طهران
من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي من قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومن قبل بريطانيا في
مساله حقوق الانسان باعتبار ان هذا الملف
والملف الذي فتح لطهران بعد ما دخل
الاتفاق النووي في حاله غيبوبه وكذلك بعد
الصمت فيما يخص الملفات الاقليميه الان
يبدو ان طهران تطارد من باب حقوق الانسان
فيبدوا ان الرساله الواضحه من طهران بهذا
الاعدام الخامس انها تقول بان هذا الملف
تراجع فيه اذا ما كان عنوانه استهداف
الامن القومي الايراني التجسس على المصانع
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه وبالتالي لن تخضع
للعقوبات التي يمكن ان تفرض عليها من هذا
الباب وندن فرضت عقوبات على نائب العمل
ايراني على خلفيات تنفيذ حكم الاعدام في
همم علي رضا اكبر اسد الله الصاوي في لندن
همم كيف يجري التعامل مع استدعاء السفيره
البريطاني في طهران
الحكومه البريطانيه اعدام علي رضا اكبر
المواطن
الايرانيه البريطاني وهناك حاله من ربما
ترقب لما ستقوم به الحكومه البريطانيه في
مقبل الايام بتنسيق مع حلفائها في الغرب
حتى الان قامت الحكومه البريطانيه
باجراءين اولا فرض عقوبات على النائب
العام الايراني وقال وزير الخارجيه جيمر
في تغريده له على تويتر يعتبر او ان
بريطانيا تعتبر ان النائب العام الايراني
هو مسؤول بشكل اساسي عن تطبيقه عقوبه
الاعدام في ايران الاجراء الثانيه هو
استدعاء القائم بالاعمال الايرانيه في همم
لندن
واخباره بريطانيا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكاني مش مزاز بريطانيا
من الواضح من خلال تصريحات المسؤولين
البريطانيين انه كان هناك محاولات
واتصالات بريطانيه مع ايران من اجل
اثنائها عن عمليه اعدام اكبر ولكن يبدو ان
هذه المحاولات من لغه الخطاب البريطانيه
يبدا انها فشلت قبل ايام جيمس بليفر
ليوزير الخارجيه قال في تغريده قبل ايام
ان النظام الايرانيه عليه ان يتوقف عن
عمليه الاعدام هذه واتهمه بانه نظام بربري
وهمرجي عاده نجد هذه اللغه بعد تنفيذ
عمليات الاعدام ربما او بعد همم الوصول
الى مرحله من القطيعه او شبه القطيعه بين
الجانبين البريطاني والايراني ولكن هذه
المره سبقت هذه اللغه عمليه الاعدام فيما
بدا انه يفسر ان ايران مصممه على المضيق
قدما فيها هذا الاعدام وانها لا تلتفت ولا
تلقي النداءات وال- همم المحاولات
البريطانيه لوقتها هذه
عمليه همم رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه ايضا
ريشي سوناك عبر في وقت مبكر من الصباح اا
اليوم عن اا حسب تعبيره ذهوله وصدمته
واشمئزازه من هذه الخطوه يعتبر ان النظام
الايراني نظام الهمجي لا يقيم اي قيمه
لحقوق الانسان في التعامل مع شعبه يشار
الى ان همم اكبر كان مساعد لوزير الدفاع
الايرانيه قبل اكثر من 20 عاما وبالتالي
همم يعني هو لين لم يحمل همم منصبه او
منصب الرسمي لم يشغل منصب الرسميا في
الحكومه الايرانيه منذ سنوات عديده يشار
ايضا الى انه كان يقيم خارج ايران وعاد
اليها في عام 2019 بناء على طلب من حسب
الاعلام البريطاني بناءا على طالب من احد
المسؤولين الايرانيين وانه لم يكن يشك في
انه يمكن ان يعتقل ان يشارك كذلك الى ان
الخدمه الفارسيه في همم الاذاعه
البريطانيه اداء التسجيلا لاكبر قبل عده
ايام قالت فيه ان اا وظهر في هذا التسجيل
ان اا اكبر يعني ينفي اعترافاته التي
بثتها ايران في قبل ذلك ويقول انها تمت
تحت التعذيب وانه تم تعذيبه وتم اعطائه
نوعا من العقاقير التي تذهب العقل حسب
التعبير الذي جاء منه في رسالته التي بثت
على الخدمه الفارسيه لهيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيا
شكرا جزيلا لكما